[Musique]
bonjour allait-on carats
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être en direct
du mali ce matin avec nous sur rt france
nouvelle attaque meurtrière au mali
l'intervention de l'onu d'ailleurs est
très compliqué dans ce pays avec ce qui
se passe en afghanistan à quelle est
votre analyse
concrètement quand aux dégâts de leca
voguant le combat aucun mallié et assad
et six multi d'intel d'actions violentes
mais les firmes y sont indifférents dans
les contextes mallié
en face d'une connexion entre les
acteurs la violence de ne pas nous avons
le goût pour les coups violents et de
conflits locaux et d'autre part nous
avons aussi la criminalité organisée
mm le milieu scientifique du lierre mais
c'est islamique du mali
non plus à des tensions liées à la
conjoncture donc au nom
l'accélération de l'été automne actuelle
les conflits tiens au nom
laisser aller leurs jambes et même
manipulations du communautaire à
l'instant nous devons pas nous conduire
là notamment des gens qui s'aiment à
terme on attend qu'on fera sur le
captiva les machines en mai donc pour
vous ce qui se passe dans le centre du
mali n'est pas liée directement à à ce
qu'on appelle nous ici en occident le
terrorisme djihadiste
complètement le mouvement parce que
c'est plus un peu
lassé des
t-bonds lundi et
mamies
elles mêmes l'état exclamé le 4x et
descente du mali sont plutôt des
tensions communautaires ou le pas sans
savoir
fini les laissant à takis empêcher
les
mêmes à empire
du mali sont des attaques commandos
heureusement qu'ils ont tous des
accointances avec or le configuration
communautaire km depuis mardi dans le
cas précis les 30 minutes pour le
confondre avec
objectivité il faut forcément
questionner le communautaire ils sont
forcément questionner lorenzo les fans
au plus haut niveau dit encore d'attac
en cuir commune et du coup quelle
réponse apporter aujourd'hui à ces
attaques on sait qu'à une présence
militaire française sur place mais mais
qu'ils aient diminué ces derniers temps
parce que la france a la preuve de la
force basque anne où la mission à
travers les nations unies mais également
les différentes réponses qui sont
apportées
par l'état du mali à travers quelques
opérations telles que madeco mais
l'opération kèlètigui sont en trop
d'initiatives qui concourent justement
au rituel pénible mais sauf que
la particularité des séquences fluo
centre élimine pas situer les limites il
n'est pas visible beau jeu
malheureusement on ne vous entend plus à
l'écart à
carrasso n'a justement
plus les mamies ses partenaires et
délictueuses
les gens pensent que ce sera ma porte
parce quelle réponse malheureusement
elle n'arrive pas à protéger les
populations civiles lesquels réponse
malheureusement n'a lui pas présent
s'illustrant des vagues est allé le
sondage dans les champs les clientèles
d'hivernage et vous national pas
fréquenter l'édition croire l'édition de
mars les diffamations tennis tu es là
malheureusement aujourd'hui les réponses
unitaires en limitant les conquêtes
manière lesquels passent un test s'est
retiré de l'appel elles sont nécessaires
mais ils ne suffisent pas elles doivent
être soutenues par des actions de
développement mais surtout une
différence ces différentes dépenses
militaires puissent davantage et un élu
local mais malheureusement spiti le
local et l alpinisme chiche est ce que
la france doit quitter le mali selon
vous alliez tout cas comme le com ont
fait les états unis en afghanistan
car il va quand
la poche qui avait été amorcé par le
président moh cran pour annoncer la
gesticulation ou le possible départ de
l'armée française delta lcd qui
n'annonce qu'elle est isolée parce
qu'elle n'a pas associé les chefs d'état
de sennecey lan occurrence dans
cette programmation
du rethel et face aux français d'aller
elle même et surtout intérêts de la
france de façon non concertée pourrait
justement dans les années à venir
aboutir à ce qu'on pourrait qualifier à
des îlots qui sont gouvernés pas ce goût
pour la ligue au violon
le défenseur messin il y en a en
particulier la même à vienne elle n'est
pas suffisamment ou tués cette année
malienne on n'est pas suffisamment
préparés chez la défaite face à toute
menace aujourd'hui auquel la le pays
fait l'objet comme déjà avec cette
combinaison de forces étrangères forces
alliées on n'arrive pas
à
imaginer que
naturellement
à des
particuliers merci beaucoup à lier tout
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce matin
sur rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
sociologue directeur du centre des
études sécuritaires et stratégiques au
sahel on va partir